today for our daily cancellation we turn
to florida where
in the story we're about to discuss
there are cancellations to be handed out
to everyone uh it's once again a
friday cancel fest which is my favorite
kind of friday let's read now from the
new york post report it says a florida
teen who allegedly
schemed with her mom to rig an election
for homecoming queen is being charged as
an adult
emily rose grover was 17 when she and
her mother were arrested for hacking
student accounts
and casting nearly 250 bogus votes so
she could snag the homecoming crown
but grover turned 18 last month in the
state attorney office in escambia county
confirmed tuesday that she'll be tried
as an adult grover and her mother 50
year old laura rose carroll are facing
multiple felonies for fixing the october
homecoming vote
at tate high school in pensacola carroll
is an assistant principal at bellevue
elementary school in the same county
okay now take a pause here for a minute
you might be thinking that the words
charged as an adult
and rigged a homecoming queen election
should not appear in the same sentence
together this would seem to be
an enormously out of proportion penalty
given the nature of the offense
but maybe the rest of the story will
change your mind or maybe it won't
continuing an investigation into the
vote was sparked
a month after the election when escambia
county school district officials
reported unauthorized access to student
accounts
investigators said they found 117 votes
originated from the same ip address over
a short period of time a total of 246
votes were cast
from accounts that were accessed by
computers inside the mom and daughters
pensacola home
or from carol's cell phone some students
said grover had boasted about using her
mother's school district account to cast
the votes
investigators learned that since august
2019 carroll's account accessed 372 high
school records
and 339 of those were tate students
charges against the mom and daughter
included unlawful use of a two-way
communications device
and criminal use of personally
identifiable information
each faces a maximum of 16 years on the
charges
and grover was expelled from her high
school according to the ap
all right so no actually the rest of the
story really doesn't change the initial
judgment
that this is a wildly overboard response
yes they access student accounts to rig
the homecoming election
uh that's bad but it's a homecoming
election
now if the if the article had said that
they had murdered her potential
challengers to the throne
and buried them in the woods in order to
win homecoming queen i'd agree that
felony charges and many years in prison
would be in order but for this
why is the court system concerned
concerning itself with this at
all is life in escambia county so
sunny and perfect and conflict-free that
they have time to use the criminal
courts to litigate a homecoming election
controversy i would have thought that
this offense
would warrant maybe a few days of
after-school detention or suspension at
most but arrest
expulsion and 16 years in prison
this is like deer hunting with an m60
the the term overkill doesn't even begin
to cover it
but that's not even what makes this case
especially outrageous
for that we have to harken back to
another story from a few weeks ago
you might recall this a reading now from
the post-millennial says the two teen
girls who were charged with murder after
allegedly attempting to hijack the car
of a pakistani immigrant working for a
food delivery app
have reached a plea deal with
prosecutors according to the daily mail
the mail reports
that the plea deal ensures that they
will not be held past the age of 21 nor
be placed in a prison facility
disturbing video of the incident shows
muhammad on war 66 being killed after
the girls allegedly sped off with his
car as he attempted to
hold on to his vehicle while drove off
the car then crashed and flipped on its
side killing on war the suspects are a
13 year old
from southeast dc and a 15 year old from
fort worth washington
the juveniles names were not released so
two teen girls who carjacked a guy
killed him in the process and left him
for dead on the sidewalk while they
frantically tried to save their phones
from the wreck
were not charged as adults and faced no
prison time at all but a teen girl
who rigged a homecoming election will be
charged as an adult
and faces a decade and a half behind
bars
does that make any sense what exactly is
the message we're getting from the
justice system here
that it's kind of bad to kill a guy for
his car but to fraudulently claim the
title of homecoming queen is an atrocity
on a whole new level
that theft and murder are mere youthful
indiscretions but sending in fake votes
for homecoming queen
isn't that two girls who killed a man
and cared more for their lost phones
than his lost life
present no threat to the community but
the silly girl who cheated the system so
she could wear a tierra and a sash for a
night
has to be locked in a cage in order to
protect the innocent
perhaps that that's the message or the
message is that
justice has become a mostly random and
arbitrary thing in this country
and it's very often determined by the
ideological bent of the person doling it
out
now it's fair to point out that these
are two different jurisdictions
right florida and dc perhaps down in
florida
where they give the homecoming queen 16
years
maybe they'd give the carjacking
murderers 16 decades
that's certainly possible but it still
does provide a stark contrast
and also can't help but note
just one more piece of evidence that
white privilege is an imaginary
construction of the left
it's not a reality because
the girl getting the book thrown at her
is white the girls who got a slap on the
wrist for killing another human being
are black now even if they're different
jurisdictions
this is certainly not the sort of
dichotomy you would envision
in a country with white privilege you
know if someone if someone on the left
if you didn't know anything about this
country and someone on the left told you
about white privilege
and then you saw these two stories you'd
be really really confused
in fact you'd probably envision
something like the exact
reverse of this situation
so what does that tell you well it tells
you for one thing
that the white privilege myth is
canceled and so is florida
and so is this girl's mom because
obviously she's the one who should get
almost all the blame for this
crime in the first place i can say that
when i was 17 if my parents came to me
and suggested
suggested that i cheat on anything
and offered to help me do it my response
at that age would have been really hell
yeah let's go
what 17 year old wouldn't have that
reaction to their own parents suggesting
that they cheat so the mom is canceled
along with the whole state and dc is
canceled also
and everyone else remotely connected to
either of these stories
is cancer just how i like to end it on a
friday
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt well show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content